kein Wasser kein Schilfrohr keine Vögel
keine Fische mehr
das mesopotamische Marschland war einst
der Ort an dem der biblische Garten Eden
vermutet wurde heute ist der größte Teil
nur noch Wüste
vergeblich versucht ein Wasserbüffel
seinen Körper zu kühlen
Fahrt auf dem Euphrat
wir erkunden die letzten Reste der
Feuchtgebiete und fahren vorbei an
veränderten Tieren im Fluss
überall erfahre ich haben die Einwohner
mit ihrem Leben hier abgeschlossen sind
dabei eine alte Kultur aufzugeben
Abo Haider ist einer der letzten
wir erleben die Zerstörung der
schilfsümpfe alle büffelzüchter alle
Fische hier werden verschwinden früher
konntest du allein hier 150 Familien
finden jetzt vielleicht nur zehn sie
sterben aus
als wir die Menschen hier besuchen haben
sie einen Sommer der Hölle hinter sich
Temperaturen von über 55 Grad ja für
Jahr mehr Hitzerekorde es war als ob das
Wasser kochte erzählen sie
seine Tiere sind kaum noch etwas Wert 3
hat sie mit Kasim schon verloren dieses
Jahr sie begannen sich hin und her zu
werfen wurden wahnsinnig weil sie die
Hitze nicht ertrugen
früher badeten die Tiere in hohem Wasser
es war Süßwasser damals sie aßen Gras
Schilfrohr und Kräuter sie hatten Futter
jetzt ist es hier fast trocken das
seichte Wasser ist salzig und grünlich
wir müssen sie mit Gras und Mehl füttern
um ihre Mägen zu stopfen
lange können Sie sich das nicht mehr
leisten sagt seine Frau die Tiere sind
ihr so teuer wie ihre Kinder aber alle
Verwandten haben das Feuchtgebiet
bereits verlassen und arbeiten als
Tagelöhner in den Städten
was können wir tun wo können wir noch
hin ich habe Angst wie soll ich keine
Angst haben das ist doch unser Leben
hier
was im Irak passiert ist ein düsteres
Fenster in die Zukunft vieler Teile der
Welt mahnen Wissenschaftler
in 20 Jahren könnten Euphrat und Tigris
die hauptwasserquellen Iraks Austrocknen
die Ursachen sind vielfältig Klimawandel
Wasserverschwendung im Irak und in den
Nachbarländern Iran und Türkei die
ihrerseits unter der Dürre leiden immer
mehr Dämme und Umleitungen der Zuflüsse
zehntausende Iraker verlassen die Dörfer
ziehen in die Städte
Sandstürme vervielfachen sich sie
fordern tausende Opfer
der südlichste Punkt des Irak dort wo
der schattel arab in den Euphrat und
Tigris gemündet sind in den persischen
goldvlies der Wissenschaftler hessand
Halil erklärt mir was der niedrige
Wasserstand des Flusses schattel arabier
verursacht die Meeresfluten können jetzt
weiter ins Landesinnere vorrücken die
Südspitze des Irak könnte bald unter
Wasser stehen keine Tage
vermischte sich für gewöhnlich das
Meerwasser mit dem Süßwasser aus Euphrat
Tigris und den iranischen Flüssen
aber jetzt kommt überhaupt kein
Süßwasser mehr hier an
weil es Strom aufwärts blockiert und
dort verbraucht wird
einst war die Gegend hier ein großer
grüner Teppich
voller Gärten Obstbäume Palmen die
Datteln von alfao wurden in alle Welt
exportiert aber alles verdorrte und
starb als das Wasser hier zu salzig
wurde
ich bin verzweifelt von diesen Palmen
lebten viele Familien in dieser Gegend
was für eine Zukunft haben jetzt unsere
Kinder sie werden von diesem Land nicht
mehr leben können
die Landschaft verändert sich
Wahrzeichen des Irak verschwinden hier
erstreckte sich der sauersee
einwohnererzählen wie hier tausende
Touristen badeten ich kann nicht glauben
dass jetzt nur noch kleine salzhügel
übrig sind im Sommer trocknete der See
aus
wir fahren weiter in den Norden in die
kurdischen Gebiete ich will wissen wie
es stromaufwärts aussieht nah der
türkischen Grenze
im Stausee von Dohuk ist der Wasserstand
so niedrig wie nie die Behörden können
laut eigenen Aussagen nicht einmal 10%
des benötigten Trinkwassers
bereitstellen
seravan magietralif blickt auf seine
Felder wenn es in den nächsten Monaten
gott behüte keinen Regen gibt wird er
fast alles aufgeben müssen sagt er
keine Ernte kein Gras
seinen Schafen geht das Futter aus also
bleibe ihm nichts anderes übrig als sie
nun die Blätter seiner Reben und
Olivenbäume Essen zu lassen
der Landwirt nimmt uns mit auf seine
Weizenfelder 90 Prozent ihrer
Weizenernte haben Iraks Bauern dieses
Jahr verloren das Getreide wuchs kaum
und die wenigen Körner könne er nur noch
als Tierfutter verwenden
unsere Zukunft steht auf dem Spiel wenn
es keinen Regen gibt gibt es keinen
Weizen keine Gerste keine Schafe keine
Bienen keine Obstbäume kein Grundwasser
mehr die Staudämme werden Austrocknen
alles wird zur Wüste
Iraks Erde zählte zu den fruchtbarsten
der Welt sie ernährte eine ganze Nation
aber das ist jetzt Geschichte